hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a 2017 french science fiction
and fantasy movie called alone or soul
the movie begins with a girl named layla
who takes part in car racing upon
reaching the finish line she takes off
his helmet with a tear on her face
the scene jumps to a news report about
the kidnapping of saul berthier whose
body has been found dead
turns out that layla's brother asam is
hospitalized due to an accident and
somehow layla is feeling guilty about
that
the next day she wakes up and continues
her boring life as a student while
jogging with her friends suddenly two of
her classmates engage in a fight and one
of them makes fun of layla's brother
which makes her mad and she ends up
kicking the girl in the face
later in the evening she goes to the
amusement park by herself
she seems to be a brave girl as she
dares to write a scream machine
the next day she wakes up but cannot
find anybody in the house her parents
are missing
she can't contact anyone as there's no
signal at all there
she takes her bicycle and goes out only
to find out that people in the
neighborhood have completely disappeared
she continues exploring the city and
runs to the hospital but her brother has
disappeared as well
a few moments later she realizes she is
not alone as she spots two kids camille
and terry and they decide to stick
together and go to the police station
upon arrival they find the third
survivor who got locked in the police
station dogi however he seems to be not
a very friendly guy as he immediately
leaves them with a stolen motorcycle
after they save him from there
laila suggests they go to the business
district to get a broader view of the
town
terry steals a gun from the police
station and the teens arrive at the
center of the city where they spot a sos
message on a building they immediately
get inside the building and go up by
using the lift
suddenly the lift stops halfway and a
mysterious voice tells them to disarm
their gun and bags
after that the lift continues to go up
upon arriving upstairs they meet the
person behind the mysterious voice a
rich boy named yvonne
as expected from the top of the building
they can't find any movement across the
city they believe that people have been
evacuated while they were asleep due to
an unexplained accident yvonne then
takes his new friends to his father's
car collection and the gang continues
seeking for help with yvonne dad's ford
mustang in a tunnel they find dodie who
is shot in the chest
they steal an ambulance and suddenly
they are attacked by arrows
luckily layla is a decent driver and
they manage to escape from there they
stop at a five-star hotel and decide to
spend a night there layla manages to
pull out the arrow from dodi's chest
saving him from death
the kids are enjoying their time at the
hotel but they don't realize that they
have been secretly followed by a drone
the next day laila asks dodie whether he
saw the shooter or not but he claims
that he didn't see anything there
dodie is upset because he thinks ivan is
racist and immediately goes away from
there
laila and the others decide to follow
him to find a clue they eventually
arrive at the border of the city finding
a thick fog blocking their way the fog
surrounds the whole city making it
impossible for them to escape from there
a few moments later the gang arrives at
camille's apartment and attempts to find
other people while yvonne stays in the
car
however the wishy-washy ivan later
decides to follow the others causing the
car to move by itself
camille is frustrated and starts
breaking and throwing stuff telling
layla that she wants to see her mother
again
layla then spots their cars in the
parking garage and attempts to reach the
car
however she realizes that somebody with
a mask has been hiding at the back seat
and she runs away from there the masked
man chases after the kids and barely
captures layla but luckily they managed
to flee with a stolen school bus
terry shows the recording of the masked
man previously and decides to name him
steelman
later in the night terry asked dodie why
he got captured by the police but he is
not willing to answer that the next day
the gang returns to yvonne's house which
is a bank and steals a bank armored car
hoping that they can get through the
huge fog with it they realize that the
fog is moving and is getting closer to
them
suddenly someone is speaking through the
radio warning them not to drive through
the fog the voice says that he will help
them and they decide to give the five
stars hotel coordinates since they
cannot find any signal there they return
to the hotel and finally have the
opportunity to get to know each other
later that night the drunkyvon wakes
layla up and hands over the gun to her
saying that he saw someone in the hotel
suddenly the steelman appears and chases
after layla even though she has a gun
with her she chooses to run away and
locks herself in a janitor doogie comes
to help but the steelman manages to flee
from the hotel
the fog is getting closer to them while
a drone is secretly monitoring camille
the next day doji goes away while yvonne
claims that he doesn't remember what
happened yesterday
laila follows dodie and arrives at an
old church he doesn't believe that the
man on the radio will come and help them
suddenly they spot a flare fired from
the hotel and immediately rush back to
there things get worse when they
discover that camille has been kidnapped
a drone that appears in front of them
forcing them to follow it if they want
camille to survive
the drone leads them to an abandoned
building
however it tells them that only dogi can
enter the building while the rest stay
outside before he goes leila hands over
her gun to him and hugs him
five minutes have passed but dodie
hasn't come out thus laila decides to go
in alone only to find out that the man
she loves has been killed suddenly this
steelman appears choking her and
attempting to kill her with his knife
she is unable to fight back but luckily
terry comes on time and hits him
ruthlessly they capture him and bury
dodie after that they bring the steelman
to the old church and layla starts
questioning him however the steelman is
mute so they can't gather any
information from him terry recognizes
the logo from his shirt telling that the
steelman belongs to his mother's
association which helps young people
with disability because of that layla
spares his life
she then finds dodie's hidden note and
discovers that he was captured because
he accidentally shot a man who kept
hurting his mom
they make contact with the man in the
audio again and give him their current
coordinate turns out that he is the one
who kidnapped camille
suddenly the fog breaks through the
church forcing the kids to run away from
there a few moments later they realize
that the kidnapper is hiding in a circus
and they decide to sneak in there they
eventually find camille who is being
locked inside a box by saul a
white-haired man that was seen on the
news at the beginning of the movie
turns out that it's all who ordered the
steelman to murder dodie because he
fails to execute the other kids saul
shoots him with his arrow and kills him
instantly
the kids show themselves up and threaten
to shoot him if he doesn't comply
however saul reveals an unsettling truth
to them
he tells them that a fire broke out in
the amusement park where layla visited
earlier several days ago
terry shoots him to shut him up from
talking nonsense
saul then gives layla a flyer which
makes her frustrated and hopeless she
finally remembers what happened before
she saw camille yvonne dodie and terry
in the amusement park
she eventually realizes that they are
already dead because all of them were
killed in the fire accident
yvonne sees the flyer and finally
understands the truth too
realizing that they are dead and cannot
die twice layla immediately rushes to
dodie's grave and saves him from there
the girl then tells the truth to dodi
who seems confused about what happened
previously
she adds that everything happening right
now is just her imagination and none of
them are real
the next day the other kids are shocked
when they see dodie is alive
in her dream asam suggests layla to
cross the fog and she suddenly wakes up
the gang finally decide to go through
the fog hoping to find paradise after a
long and rough journey they reach the
other side of the fog where they find a
huge and magnificent building and they
walk towards it upon arrival they meet a
lot of people who presumably have died
in the real world
at the end of the movie it is seen that
saul is standing on the top of a
building indicating that he is the
leader of the community there
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching